uh we're actually going to begin with
voting and the record turnout in early
voting in the Battleground state of
Georgia people there want their voices
heard partly due to a closely watched
Governor's race which is a rematch from
four years ago also a tight Senate race
that could help determine control of
Congress Nicole Killian is following it
all for us in Georgia once again Nicole
good morning
hey good morning to you Tony and on this
last day of early voting officials are
once again bracing for record turnout in
fact you can see behind me there is a
line already starting to form at this
polling location doesn't open for
another hour more than 2 million people
have cast their ballots that's out of
nearly 7 million active voters and
here's a look at who's voting a little
more than half are women the majority
are over the age of 50 with the largest
turnout among whites and African
Americans we recently sat down with
Republican incumbent Governor Brian Kemp
and Democratic Challenger Stacey Abrams
who are in a rematch from their 2018
contest both said they were encouraged
by the numbers but they played down
polls that show them separated by single
digits the senate race of course is much
tighter between Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock and GOP nominee Herschel
Walker who are locked in a virtual tie
so the bottom line is that if neither
candidate clears 50 percent next week
then these races are headed to a runoff
into December so instead of election day
we could be talking about election month
Nate Nicole thank you